got so on this one it's not me coming up
and then sort of like you know my hand
yeah he can kick me see so if I just if
I hit a him and then he sees that I
can't the rest of the
technique so all what I've been showing
you is
here I've got to quickly go from here
here all the way down body
and Nimble from but no it's a it's the
sort of word it's sort of flexible you
got be
flexible but I'm doing the same as
I'm expressing I'm expressing
myself can't
go there up there's no
Dynamics so I'm stuck here I'm going to
go
hit
over i' be that way if it was ke be
looking at but this way this this from
the multiple
attack down here here you throw and you
then to these people so that's when I
say you know n
me so so you've got to be able to go
from here to there smoothly and
dynamically but you can only motivate
yourself nobody else can do it for you
technique won't do it for you so you
have to do it
in but don't take your hand
off everybody's got it everybody's doing
this see the hands and it lies down
there it could kick me
away here I'm holding his body
off
here I can use the hand blade or I can
use the arm
your stature and arm length depends
whether you go down the hand blade or
whether you go down I did with the
forarm